last night's episode of America's Got
Talent may have been their most moving
ever it even brought the show's toughest
judge to tears I was trying to hold it
together Michael let it out that's dad I
can't imagine what you've done and
you're a really really special guy and I
don't know something about you maybe
want to start crying
[Music]
Simon's raw reaction was not just
triggered by the powerful performance
off his golden buzzer recipient Michael
kettle but by the pediatric nurses
selfless story
it was poignant li told through his five
adopted sons leading into the
performance I was the actor my penis
when it hurt us yeah
what he started to change those kids
lights he's a really really special
person we were with the family today
really surprising I got to see Simon
cried so they never cried before because
they're both fathers and when my dad's
sing that song so I mean just got it
they have quite the love story when
Michael and his wife Ivy's daughter was
six years old they first adopted the
three brothers Jared chase and Riya next
came Sean and then little rowdy who
lives with cerebral palsy what's the
first thing you guys did ran up and
tackled me back in the back right he
said fun fun that might be good that's a
good that's good
[Music]